so these are three hard x.x to follow
especially Stephanie who I have heard
talk before but I think she brings
really to life literally so much of what
all of the rest of us are trying to work
with and study and understand but I also
want to thank George very very much for
really i think outstanding presentation
and i feel very grateful to you George
that you were able and willing to come
and participate in this event and Zoe
too i think is one of the most exciting
young people I've worked with in a long
time so thank you so much for a
wonderful talk and I also want to thank
all of you for coming tonight to help us
celebrate the launch of what I think is
the first-ever Center for complicated
grief certainly the first-ever
university-based center for complicated
grief the center would never have been
established without the strong support
and dedicated efforts of Dean Nakamura
and her wonderful administrative team
here at the school of social work also
our center activities are possible only
because of the contributions of a very
long list of people who provided a great
deal of different kinds of input and I
could just spend the rest of the time
that I'm going to talk to you listing
them all so I decided to I didn't want
to like not mention them but I'm
limiting the list to a few of the people
who have played an especially important
role first of all I want to mention
Nicole Anderson who's taken on the full
range of activities administrative
activities that are central to every
aspect of our functioning Bevan Campbell
has a leadership role in our new train
the trainer's program Natalia skirts kya
has provided support
input throughout all phases of the
center development Nicole Alston is our
community liaison and her contributions
have been very very critical and
stephanie has been a consultant to us
and a very dedicated member of our team
and companion as we've developed this
Center additionally the intellectual
roots of this effort are planted very
firmly in the developmental
psychobiology laboratory of Myron hofer
who were very fortunate to have here
this evening who I first met in the late
1970s along with Harry share and Susan
Brunelli when I worked with them under
an n IM ht-32 fellowship in Myron's lab
important intellectual nourishment also
came from brief burst researchers like
George who I met at least amet i think
when i first started this work and whose
work has always been very very important
to my own thinking but also a number of
other people a few of them include Paula
Clayton Sydney's Idzik Robert niemeyer
and Holly Pregerson none of whom are
here tonight and clinical researchers
aetna FOA Ellen Frank David kupfer
Charles Reynolds and Naomi Simon none of
whom are here tonight and biostatistical
colleagues Philip lavori Joel greenhouse
nigh wadhwan Melanie wall and you enjoy
Wang and lastly I would not have come to
the school of social work at all if it
weren't for the imagination
encouragement and support of my close
friend and Kaplan who you will hear from
shortly again there are many many others
who deserve mention but time doesn't
permit me to review the whole list of
people to whom the center owes its
existence because I do want to tell you
a little bit about what we're doing why
do we need Center for complicated grief
and you've heard a little bit about that
already but I'll tell you my perspective
if so lost as we've been saying is a
natural part of life that affects us I
think in a manner somewhat similar
somewhat analogous really to the way
that injury or illness does it disrupts
our usual functioning and it also
triggers a natural healing process
George as he pointed out and others have
taught us that for most people the
disruption is actually not so great and
or we heal in a natural environment with
support from friends and family without
any kind of clinical intervention
healing after loss means comprehending
its finality understanding all that it
means that a loved one is no longer in
our lives and being able to envision a
future that has purpose and meaning and
the possibility for joy and satisfaction
even though this person is gone most of
us do heal this way but some don't so
over the past three decades we've
learned that we can reliably identify a
subgroup of about ten percent of briefed
people for whom the natural healing
process is derailed as Stephanie so
eloquently described and this is the
problem we call complicated grief just
to be clear about it we use the term
complicated not in the ordinary sense of
the word but in the medical sense which
refers to a superimposed process that
interferes with the natural healing of
another condition in this case
bereavement so my research group has
been working since the mid-1990s to
develop and test methods for recognizing
understanding and treating the
complicating processes in order to
permit natural healing to take over
there's a pressing need to help people
with complicated grief using the most
recent epidemiologic estimates there
about their
there are about 10 million people 10
million individuals in the United States
alone who are suffering in this way so
Stephanie is certainly not alone in 2009
my colleague niwot Wan developed a
guesstimate he called it of the rates
and consequences of untreated CG that
turned out to fit reasonably well with
subsequent epidemiologic findings
according to Nawaz guesstimate CG costs
our country about 35 billion dollars
each year in lost productivity and
accounts for about five percent of
currently unemployed people importantly
to the lives of friends and loved ones
are often very impacted by a person with
this problem especially again as
Stephanie pointed out their children's
lives CG has been associated with
medical illness including cardiovascular
illness and cancer and with suicidality
so given its prevalence and impact we
set out to tell it to develop methods
and tools to facilitate clinical work
with people suffering from cg we
constructed and validated screening
instruments structured diagnostic
interview cognitive and behavioral
assessment scales and a collection of
forms and handouts for use in a
manualized 616 session treatment that's
been efficacy tested and that Stephanie
told you a little about our treatment
approach is based upon an attachment
theory model of bereavement that directs
attention to brain circuitry known to be
involved in close relationships as Zoe
pointed out the model posits the healing
after loss entails learning and emotion
regulation in a process that includes
coping with both loss and restoration
related problems in tandem and that
proceeds most effectively in the context
of strong supportive companionship the
treatment comprises
a set of well-developed procedures
individualized to fit the needs of each
person the treatment is structured
because we believe structure is helpful
to people being assaulted by strong
emotions and it utilizes some simple
psychotherapeutic principles that track
through the 16 sessions these include an
emphasis on self observation and
reflection the use of imagery which
fosters implicit learning especially
Foster's implicit learning and
facilitates emotion activation and
encouragement of positive emotions which
can nurture creativity and
problem-solving signature techniques in
this treatment our imaginal revisiting
imaginal conversation with the deceased
person situational revisiting personal
aspirations and goals work work with
memories and pictures and meeting with a
significant other we've been funded by
the NIH for three different randomized
controlled trials of this treatment one
of which was completed and published in
2005 a second that is just ended
recruitment in a third that is ongoing
our first study documented cgt efficacy
and a dissertation study by Kim Glickman
a PhD candidate here at the school of
social work who couldn't be here with us
tonight has identified likely mediators
of its effectiveness the dissertation of
Angela guess choir who is here with us
tonight a recent and a recent Columbia
doctor'll graduate focused on help
seeking and confirm the fact that
dissemination of our clinical materials
and information is the critical next
step in our work so the mission of the
center for complicated grief is simple
we want to improve the lives of people
suffering with this condition how are we
going to do this our primary objective
is as I've said I think December
nation of knowledge the center has
established partnerships with colleagues
at Columbia some of whom you've heard
from this evening others in New York
City elsewhere in the United States and
globally in order to share information
trained clinicians and support
innovative research we've begun programs
that we hope will raise awareness of CG
in the population at large we seek to
reach CG sufferers as well as their
friends family members and colleagues we
hope to make widely available our CG
related assessment and therapeutic tools
and methods so that clinicians in health
and mental health settings can make use
of these effectively we're beginning a
project to revamp our existing website
in order to utilize web-based and social
media tools to disseminate information
as widely and as effectively as possible
we've begun a year-long train the
trainer's program that will produce
experienced clinicians who can teach
others there are local participants in
this project in this program as well as
individuals from California Boston and
Pennsylvania and from Italy Ireland
Canada in China we're working to develop
and test curriculum for graduate
postmasters and postdoctoral education
of mental health professionals we're
developing methods to provide
consultation and support for researchers
doing clinical research and we're hoping
to be able to develop seed money
research program to stimulate innovative
projects from young investigators like
Zoe death and loss are weighty topics
ones that most of us naturally shy away
from sometimes when I tell my friends I
work to help people who have lost loved
ones and are struggling with intense
unrelenting grief they change the
subject or they tell me they don't have
much interest in this topic that is
until they experience it partly as a
result of this aversion many are caught
off guard when they lose a loved one
including some of the most introspective
deep thinking and creative people in our
culture people like Joan Didion Megan
O'Rourke and joyce carol oates a basic
assumption of our Center and one that
provides a guiding framework for our
activities is that grief is a community
affair Megan O'Rourke has a simple
elegant way of saying this as she has up
saying most things she writes I believe
in the importance of individuality but
in the midst of grief i also find myself
wanting connection wanting to be
reminded that the sadness i feel is not
just mine but ours when we in the
helping professions adopt this
perspective and open our eyes to the
problems of death and loss and grief we
can provide a great and needed service
and simultaneously deepen our own
humanity and sense of community it is in
this spirit of community that we are
here tonight celebrating the launch of
the Center for complicated grief and the
reason why the center belongs here at
Columbia University School of Social
Work
you